alors j'ai un scoop sûrement gims parce
qu'on peut plus appeler maître gims
depuis hier vous êtes au courant je sais
comment il a été annoncé il veut plus
quoi permettre à m6 devront appel gims
j'ai deux couples le premier c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'il va dans un hôtel
truqués restaurant machin il veut une
omelette à chaque fois c'est drôle donc
enfin c'était un bon exemple un deuxième
succès qui vient d'enregistrer un son
avec car diby ah ouais c'est vrai mais
parce que ça m'intéresse
non non ce qui fait de la protéine
tennis seront faits par leurs examens en
dollars et hessa quéré atterré c'est
quoi aabar materi père et intérêts à
capa de mal c'est quoi le jeune couple
fait rascasse il a enregistré un saut
avec avec car diby de la queen car diby
quoi ça c'est pas mal ça oui c'est pas
mal est ce que c'est un enregistrement
comme ils font d'habitude chacun effet
d'un côté vous y il fait pas dans la
copie c'est d'accord mais c'est marc
navire haute et à très bon ça catherine
la première 20 ans et montage c'est qui
car des beignets ne s'est pas justement
j'ai demandé à des fins de scoop daniel
moreau a fait un compte instagram cette
semaine amusant alors là pour
l'ascension formation donc je ne sais
pas encore matières douces des amis on
avance un petit peu on passe à quel
scoop
myriam et là c'est là pardon alors je
vais pas parler d'un tennisman où je
voulais parler d'un footballeur qui a un
énorme grand coeur même si ça m'embête
en fait de l'avouer pourquoi a en fait
il y là il a fait à quelque chose de
bien grâce à nous donc quelque part on
participe aussi de magath se dit qu en
fait il nous a c'est qu'il ya des maps
et il nous a attaqués parce qu'un bon ou
fait cet été une petite pas par anna de
lui et j'ai trouvé vachement bien parce
que les frais juridiques qu'il a gagné
les a tous reversés à une oeuvre
caritative
c'est combien entre 3
l'aide que vous avez vous tu dois faire
un lui sert de robots d'accord et c'est
très rare il faut le noter beaucoup du
fond et ne le font pas en fait de fait
rare c'est vrai ah oui vous dévoile à
lui rendre hommage même si j'aurais
préféré qu'ils nous attaquent pas